(applause)
- Let's see what made
Drew's News mood board.
First, in a new piece on Vogue.com,
a young millennial writer
says she got a landline
and it changed her life.
Yeah!
The essay covers all the
benefits landlines are great for,
working from home,
they work in an emergency
except for mine who's attached to cable
so when the power goes
out, it all goes out
and they give your sweet little peepers
a break from that cell phone
that you just can't stop staring at.
Okay, now for those young
people watching at home
who think, what is this?
This is a telephone
and I'm here to show you how it's done.
First, you pick up the receiver,
(sighs)
that's right,
that's this part right here.
And then you think of
your bestie's phone number
which you have saved in your mind.
It's seven digits if
they're local (clicking),
11 if they're in a
different area code, 310.
Now in the 917-212's, oh yeah, 212,
that's a hot area code.
While the other side rings,
you can fiddle with this
curly thing we call a cord
and then your bestie picks up
and you talk about boys and girls and life
and it's like the best.
It's a thing of beauty
and I'm so glad that
they're making a comeback,
by the way, this is my
personal phone from my bedroom.
There are two stories
that I love to follow,
two sites, excuse me,
one is Tank's Good News
and he'll be here on the
show with us this month
and another is Upworthy,
and if you're not following
either of these sites,
trust me, I really believe
that they will make
your life happier, okay.
So go to our website and I'll
link you to both of them.
So I saw this post on Upworthy
and it gave a woman,
oh, that's what it is,
a woman she gave serious
thought to her LinkedIn profile.
Lauren G saw her perfectly
polished power pose
and it didn't,
and she didn't feel like it
portrayed who she really was,
and so, to show some authenticity,
she replaced it with a
less professional one
and put up a much more real pic
of a mom balancing everything in her life.
Lauren, I think you really represent
how a lot of people feel this year.
Okay, let's lift up the veil,
get rid of the veneer
and proudly be our authentic self.
(applause)
Thank you, Lauren G.
I know, I love this.
Oh! Time for a beauty junkie alert.
(applause)
So guess what? It's official,
banana clips are back, okay.
Yeah.
The New York Post reports
that the banana clip
has seen increased interest
and getting Googled and
pinned more than ever.
How scary that they know that?
(audience laughs)
It might not seem wow worthy,
but just check out this hairstyle
Kristen Bell rocked with this bad boy.
Yeah, I think that's super foxy.
Banana clips are wow worthy.
Oh, and speaking of bananas,
we had to say goodbye to Carole Baskin,
the cat queen herself on
Dancing With The Stars.
She gave it her all though
and for her last dance,
she performed the samba
to the "Circle of Life"
dressed as a lion because of course,
Carole Baskin, lion,
so, so long for now,
you cool cat and kitten.
Oh my God, by the way,
if you need more Tiger
King 'cause everybody does,
check out the documentary special
on the channel Investigation Discovery.
It just came out this week.
Get it while it's hot.
(applause)
(upbeat music)